bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
katell qui représente la société
romina fort au départ et romy paris
[Musique]
ces deux-là berne autocritique
cosmétiques franchissez encore muet ce
que tu peux nous présenter parce que
vous avez une solution qui est hyper
intéressante car innovantes pour avoir
un temps idéal
alors du coup revue paris qu'une jeune
maison de cosmétiques française nous
proposons à nos consommateurs ont fait
les frais pour le visage pour cela nous
avons mis
en place une technologie innovante qui a
nécessité cinq ans de recherche et
développement et
de reuver ont été déposées pour en
arriver là
et donc cette technologie on la retrouve
notamment sur la terminateur qui dure
j'avais bu city
je peux déplacer ou pas oui je vais le
mettre en application
j'allais le voir défiler tout de suite
donc figurent canon car formulateurs
avoir chez soi et en fait qui vous
permet de
formulez chez vous directement en soins
le matin et le soir et
vraiment s adapter aux besoins de votre
peau et va passer par une application
vous allez pouvoir remplir un premier
temps
en fait finalement le comment réagir de
manière générale c'est un formulaire en
fin de compte c'est une sorte de
formulaires c'est vraiment mon rêve
c'est de chercher à comprendre comment
réagit votre peau de manager général
ensuite application va pouvoir bouger
localiser et capter des éléments
externes
si vous avez des objets connectés vous
allez également pouvoir les connecter
les youtube et on tente dernière chose
pour
donner la bonne comme une douce un vous
pouvez déclarer certaines choses qui ne
sont pas de l'application pourtant qu'à
respecter comme si vous avez une
cigarette ou manger un peu foutraque
d'habitude ce genre de chose qui colle à
un algorithme été mis en place alors un
terme à thénac
et ça vous donnez une combinaison points
kipré comptez vous que
de une à trois capsules de répondre à
des actifs nous avons désactivé serment
et s'être unis longtemps var est
cependant pas répondre en fait un peu
plus loin qu à l'instant t battant le
matin vous allez voir une combinaison
vers l'actif 5 6 et 9 et le soir vous
allez avoir la ctif 1 3 est d'accord que
votre vivez votre hobby en même temps et
la journée vous mettez dessus bien donc
c'est 100% personnalisés et en fonction
des changements de saison sont créés
sont proches soleil si on est à l'année
choses comme ça ça change n'a pas
toujours le même soin vous avez pas
devenu trop bas et ne serait-ce qu'en
vivant en restant comme des récits à
paris
là le matin vous allez avant leurs
points et le fort elle en avant un autre
pas parce que la journée vous avez vécu
avec des choses a jugé vit pas deux fois
la même journée
pour rien ça la plainte contre le matin
et le soir quand votre besoin d'eux pour
change pas comme duplo vraiment proposé
on a besoin à l'instant t d'accord ça se
passe comment c'est les petites capsules
c'est ça oui elle a fait le calcul
question une capsule correspond à un
actif on a un avis différent
donc ça c'est un actif alors ça veut
dire que par exemple le matin qui montre
aux gens mais plusieurs dans la machine
alors un de l'application avons essayé
d'en être un a3 d'accord en différant
d'accord
à troyes ça me fait un mélange vraiment
personnalisé que je peux garder combien
de temps non justement le but c'est vous
insérez l'actif dans formule atteint
figure
un ou trois actifs en quelques secondes
ce avons formulé un minime de son
correspond en fait un constat pour
pour l enfant du visage du cou et des
morts s'est jamais vous dans la 4e
et le but c'est vraiment ça voulait sort
directement en un statut et voulait
appliquer directement civilisation
d'accord donc ça veut dire zéro stock je
prends je veux mais je pose donc une
vraie fraîcheur pareil le soir tous les
jours d'accord génial alors c'est un
un produit pour retrouver ou de les
soigner ou alors il est disponible sur
nos points de vente pour l'instant mais
en fin de compte pas dans le centre
commercial de parly 2 et également sur
notre site internet
kirin marchand vous pouvez retrouver qui
dure les actifs qui vont avec et nous
est produits frais sont les cures frêche
alors été formulée avec la même
technologie dans nos laboratoires
parisiens
si jamais vous n'avez pas figure comme
ça ça vous parle de même croire
produits ou les cures sont dépouillés
les produits qui s'habille comme en cinq
jours et une application matin et soir
savon pour une remise à zéro de trop et
là on va on a trois coeurs différents
qui vont répondre
vraiment un moment dit il y en a une
pour le stress pour la pollution et une
pour
à ce qui se fait des excès de poids en
gt2 l'étape vous la commander sur
internet ou sur une heure on tente on
vous la formule chez nous
laura et on vous l'expédient fraîchement
mis sous vide comme
y avait dix jours pour la consommer
parce qu on ne rajoute pas tous deux
conservateurs en micro de livres il faut
également la comptable super merci
beaucoup je vous mets le lien dans la
description pour aller voir tout ça
alors du coup c'est un produit qui est
vraiment destiné j'imagine que c'est un
public féminin
alors que total une armée finalement son
compte que
il ya beaucoup d'amour socialement elle
sait qu elle notre on a vraiment un pôle
unique ce qu'on a cherché à voir
le point
lui-même a une odeur mais quand même
assez légères c'est pas une guerre
féminines c'est l'argent promis sont
mais on sait que c'est pas du tout pour
la femme
vraiment vraiment un fin de toute façon
belle ronde face aux primaires ça avance
on est là pour équilibrer votre haut
débit ou bien aussi bien aux femmes
représentent la bombe
[Musique]
- school bon écoute merci beaucoup vous
dites moi est ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser
est-ce que vous appliquez décret mais ce
que prenez soin de votre peau sinon
falloir vous y mettre
on m'a dit si ce produit pourrait vous
intéresser est ce que le côté fraîcheur
le côté sans conservateurs vous
intéresse vous mettez tout sans
commentaires et on discute ensemble
quant à moi je vous invite mais c'est
joli pousse à vous abonner cas restez
connectés parce que encore plus de
contenu pour des convoyeurs entreprise
française innovante
puis la technologie de la tête en règle
générale à bientôt
[Musique]